You've been warned about using bioelectricity in
group before. Welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this will be my full Marvel She-Hulk episode 7
video there were a whole bunch of Easter eggs
and references so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes and careful
for spoilers for the episode if you haven't seen
it yet we'll just start at the beginning and work
our way through shot by shot talking about Easter
eggs and WTF moments and the other cool thing they
actually just confirmed was a big Wolverine Easter
egg during a previous She-Hulk episode like there
was this reference to a man fighting someone else
with metal claws in a bar in my video for that
episode in particular I called it a wolverine
reference just because it felt like a wolverine
reference to that first X-Men movie back in 2000
or was a scene like that like he had a similar
bar fight like that and it was Wolverine like
the Hugh Jackman version of Wolverine because
now we know that he's going to be in the MCU
because Ryan Reynolds just released the video
confirming that Hugh Jackman would come back as
Wolverine in Deadpool 3. but we did have one idea
hey Hugh you want to play Wolverine one more time
yeah sure and they confirmed that it'd be Canon to
the MCU now obviously it's going to be Deadpool so
it'll be super meta and they'll get super
weird with it and he'll probably make all
kinds of jokes about the Multiverse and timelines
things not making sense but I do believe that it's
meant to be the versions of those characters that
we've been seeing in all the fox Marvel movies so
make all the jokes about Deadpool killing the fox
Marvel Universe in Deadpool 3 that you want to and
speaking of mutants and X-Men characters coming
into the MCU we saw another mutant character show
up during this episode the El Aguila character
is a mutant and they have this whole joke in
the episode about him being torn between his
two different identities trying to find out
who he really was that's meant to be a comic book
reference because in the comics he pretends to be
a sword fighter like a swashbuckler as he joked
about during this episode when really he just
does that to hide the fact that he's a mutant and
his big mutant power is to create electrostatic
discharge which he does in the episode when
he uses his sword but the actual episode title
was the retreat which is a reference to the
Abomination special Retreat that he started as
a sort of new age Zen that he is teaching to the
other Marvel villains in most of these villains
are Daredevil and Punisher villains because
obviously Daredevil in the MCU now Punisher
also probably going to come back pretty soon too
I think them using Punisher villains is just a hat
tip for that they also say that Punisher villain
saracen is a vampire and I think that's meant to
be another reference to the blade movie that's
coming up like it's meant to foreshadow that
and everything that's going on with Jen and her
She-Hulk blood that they're trying to steal to the
Intelligentcia because he spent the entire part
of his episode referencing stealing people's blood
like we should go drink his blood he's just trying
to get your blood which literally is happening
like he literally calls out the episode like oh
yeah that he just wants to get your blood so that
was just like the other big reveal of the episode
is that Josh is working with the Intelligentcia in
this Hulk King character Hulk King is a reference
to hulkling in the comics that's like another
Alias that he uses but hulkling is actually a
scroll he's like the scroll Emperor but I actually
think that the leader of the Intelligentcia might
wind up being a version of the leader because he's
going to be the main villain in Captain America
four so I think they'll have some references to
that his whole thing during The Incredible Hulk
movie is that he was trying to take the Hulk's
blood like he had all these samples and he was
trying to do all this Research into Hulk's powers
and he's also the person who turned Abomination
into Abomination using Hulk's blood and the
Intelligentcia is a comic book villain group that
the leader and Modoc were both part of I don't
think Modoc is going to be in this series because
of the way they're using him in Ant-Man 3. and I
believe it's going to be like a big twist on the
character during Ant-Man 3. so I don't think that
has anything to do with this really cool side
note too the Intelligentcia and the comics were
the ones who created the Red Hook like they're
the ones that turned Thunderbolt Ross into Red
Hulk they kind of implied in previous episodes
that the whole idea is that they want to take her
blood so that they can use it to create more hulks
the actual episode starts with Jen getting out
of the shower texting Josh setting up their whole
relationship apparently he's using her to get that
game of blood like I said so he's basically
reverse honeypotting her in fact they even
foreshadow at the very beginning of the episode
with this opening scene when you're looking at
his text to her he's been trying to find where
she lives and she's like wait a minute you know
which neighborhood I live in that's like the most
sus thing of all like oh that's clearly something
a stalker would you then they have a long Montage
of their relationship over the course of the week
like they go on a bunch of dates and you see her
having a bunch of different text conversations
with him as the relationship develops until they
eventually bone at the end of the week turns out
that was his whole goal so that he could clone
all the data on her phone also during her meeting
here because she's in the superhero law Division
and that's probably what they're talking about
here whichever case they're working on when the
person says the insurance policy covers acts of
God I think what they're saying is that they're
trying to liken a super villain attack like some
superhero's powers to the act of a god which
might be a Thor reference because like there
are gods in the MCU we saw them during Thor
love and thunder but when you think about them
treating Gods being on Earth as a normal thing
usually you think about the Thor character the
whole thing with her getting the lawyer of the
Year award in the gala that Nikki mentions is
something that they'll probably pay off in the
last two episodes maybe like the finale because
there was some trailer footage of her at the gala
with this big attack where she has to hook out
and save everyone then also may be part of the
Daredevil episodes I don't know if he's going to
be in one episode or two episodes I believe next
week will be be his first episode if he's in two
but he could just be in one when they dropped the
first trailer they hadn't revealed that Daredevil
was confirmed to show up in the series so the
fact that there was so much red coloration and
red Lighting in the trailer just made everyone
think wow they're probably trying to foreshadow
Daredevil showing up you notice during their text
he uses lots of emojis which itself seems kind of
weird to begin with but also it's meant to set up
the end of the episode where they reveal he sends
all those emojis to Hulk King about stealing
her blood she uses the term Hulk smashed as
in Hulk's catchphrase Hulk smash when Nikki is
speculating on all the things that Josh could
be doing that would keep him from sending her
text she suggests silent Retreats which is meant
to foreshadow Abominations Retreat which is the
whole title of the episode also we find out the
reason why he hadn't responded to her is because
he was only trying to get into bed with her so
we could clone her data and he had no reason to
contact her after that he didn't actually like
her so it wasn't like he wanted to talk to her she
practices yoga she watches a Muppet movie The Miss
Piggy Muppets clip she's watching on her phone
is actually from the great Muppet Caper movie
which is an awesome classic Muppet movie it's like
one of the better Jim Henson era Muppet movies but
the Miss Piggy clip is also meant to be a metaphor
for her Jen She-Hulk because in the scene Miss
Piggy metaphorically hulks out in prison and bends
the bars to her prison cell and frees herself so I
think that's meant to be a metaphor or foreshadow
something that She-Hulk will eventually do like
the Intelligentcia will get the drop on her and
she'll have to save herself like she'll hook out
and go full Savage She-Hulk when she gets the
call from abomination's parole officer his name
is Chuck donnellan that's actually a reference
to Charles donalan who's a real life comic book
artist and she travels to abomination's retreat
to check on on him and based on the route that
she takes in and out of the retreat it seems
like it's in the Malibu area because remember
the whole series takes place in the Los Angeles
area so these mountains in the view of the ocean
later when she's leaving seems like it's in Malibu
the area where she is is just like super expensive
which I think is just meant to flow with the idea
that he's charging people out the money for his
New Age religion that he's teaching to people it's
sort of like a cult that he has going on here the
special meditate retreats in those seven special
women that fell in love with him basically gave
him this property when they get there the parole
officer calls her the Jolly Green Giant because
she's Giant and green Abomination claims that
his inhibitor was malfunctioning because he got
shocked by an electric fence but early theory is
that that's a lie and he was just tampering with
it and trying to remove it because there is some
later trailer footage with him walking around at
what seems like his retreat in full Abomination
form so like at some point he'd have to get out
of that inhibitor when he says he has a favorite
chicken princess silk feather like he has all
these pet chickens here I don't know if that's
also meant to be a reference to something else
or another person we'll see if it winds up being
code for something eventually they introduced
the man Bull and the El aguala character manual
is a daredevil villain who started as a man and
was turned into a half-man half bull in a lab
experiment like he says his powers are exactly
what you think they'd be and I already kind
of explained El Aguila he's actually from the
Luke Cage and Iron Fist team up Comics so like
we have a lot of the Marvel Netflix characters
coming back into the MCU now so of course there
using a lot of their villains too and because
El Aguila is a mutant and they're doing more
mutants now it also makes sense why they chose
him in particular but like pretty much all the
villains that are here are meant to be like C
and d-list villains the other weird thing that
happens in this scene when they destroy her Prius
is that she specifically calls it a Prius Prime
and they mention Prius prime a couple of times so
I'm wondering if it was part of some ad campaign
or like a commercial that they worked into the
episode like ad integration because they do that
with a lot of cards in Marvel series and movies
like that's why Iron Man drove Audis because
Audi paid Marvel a ton of money to use their
cards instead of Tesla like normally you'd expect
him to drive a Tesla when they say El Aguila's
identity as a sword fighter is a representation of
all the times he's been metaphorically stabbed in
the back betrayed by people it's a parallel for
she-hulks Josh storyline with him betraying her
just to get her blood and when he talks about
the yurt integrating the past and present into
one being that's a metaphor for She-Hulk combining
the two halves of her personality Hulk also doing
the same thing becoming the professor Banner
version of Hulk like their two sides working
together together so that they have the power of
the Hulk in their full intellect it also kind of
seems like Abomination has done a version of that
too they make this big thing about her being stuck
there because her car is waiting for a tow truck
she could actually just use she-hulk's power to
jump home super fast like the hook can run fast
of course but because their legs are so strong
they can travel even faster by just doing super
jumps like old school Superman style leaping tall
buildings in a single bound they have the special
support group scene you look in the background he
calls his special teachings abomaste the other
new characters are porcupine he's actually from
the Ant-Man and the WASP stories Tales to astonish
but he's also shown up in Iron Man X-Men Captain
America Avengers Comics his whole story is that he
was a scientist working with Hank Pym and he built
a power suit just like Hank Pym built his own
suit but his was a porcupine suit and he wound up
turning into a super villain just taking the suit
with him they use him mostly for a joke in this
episode like he's been wearing the suit for so
long that it just gets super ranked which they pay
off in the end credit scene like that new extra
scene of him actually getting it dry cleaned then
Sarah sen like I said is is the Vampire who's from
The Punisher Comics which is another clue they'll
probably bring the Punisher back eventually and
obviously we have vampires more Supernatural
characters coming through the blade movie we
also have werewolf by night that's going to
be happening in a couple weeks which is basically
like a monster MCU series like they're doing more
monsters more Supernatural characters and then
Shield breaks the fourth wall for the first time
in the episode and she also knows that she's a
character in a television show which I believe
is the first time that she's referenced that like
this is a level above normal fourth wall breaking
she calls that the previously on on the beginnings
of most episodes cueing up another one speaking to
someone off camera like she's talking to Kevin
feige in real life cue up another previously on
so we can explain who this Wrecking Crew character
is and the thing about this is like normally when
you see people do this in shows like Rick and
Morty does stuff like this every once in a while
like Rick Sanchez knows that he's a character in a
fictional TV show when characters gain the ability
to do this in stories like this it essentially
makes them the most powerful character in the
entire universe because if you think about it like
a Celeste deal could come attack her get ready to
vaporize the planet and she could literally pause
the universe by breaking the fourth ball and then
cueing something else up like okay let's just
jump to some other scene so it's like a level
Beyond The Meta that they've done before they'll
probably do more stuff like this when we get to
Deadpool 3 and because she's probably gonna come
back in Captain America 4 and obviously Avengers
5 in Avengers 6. I also wonder if she's gonna
break the fourth ball or Deadpool might be in
those movies or at least Avengers 6 will they
also break the fourth wall in the Avengers
movies but we find out that one of the members of
wrecking crew is at the retreat and now I kind of
think that Josh is actually the other member of
wrecking crew that was wearing the mask so you
couldn't identify him in the previous episode and
they already confirmed in their previous episode
when they first appeared that they were after
her blood meaning that they were working for
the Intelligentcia so like the whole idea is that
this guy is kind of lying to her during this whole
Retreat most of this though they treat for comedy
like all the super villains clown on her for her
Josh problems like what did you text him oh no you
can't do that that's terrible saracen like I said
keeps mentioning her blood foreshadowing what's
going to happen with the Intelligentcia in Josh
during the episode but also because he's a vampire
and he actually literally wants to drink blood and
because they're all super villains they want to go
kill Josh sarson wants to drink his blood and then
El Aguila uses his mutant power electrifying his
sword with his bioelectricity which Abomination
calls out and I love the idea that nobody thinks
that it's a big deal that there are mutants in
the MCU like Abomination is totally unperturbed by
it like oh yeah someone's using their biology to
create weird powers like this yeah that's totally
normal and then Abomination launches into this
big talk about being genuine showing your genuine
emotions and it just seems so over the top that I
think it might be foreshadowing for him revealing
that he's really just doing all this as a front to
try and stay out of prison like everything with
the end of this Retreat she goes into the yurt
they have all this hopeful music like all these
B and c-less super villains are all cheering for
her like it's some really hopeful cheesy moment
it just feels like they're trying to foreshadow
that this is all kind of a front it's all kind of
fake the slot tow truck is a reference to Dan slot
who's written a ton of Marvel Comics also the tow
truck driver's name is Dan so it's like literally
Dan slot tow truck he's mostly known for his time
writing Spider-Man comics but he's also written on
She-Hulk which is why I think he made it into this
episode as an Easter egg then at the end of the
episode they do a flashback three episodes earlier
to reveal that when they bone Josh copied all the
data on her phone and contacted Hulk King letting
him know that things were proceeding according to
plan so that they could eventually get her blood
which I think just based on the timing of them
paying all these storylines off will probably
happen in next week's episode at some point
and because it is the Daredevil episode I think
that also confirms that Daredevil will be part
of whatever this final Arc is with her versus the
Intelligentcia but there's no actual post-credit
scene which is kind of a bummer because they did
post-credit scenes for like most of the first half
of the season but in the end credits scene like
with the actual credits where they put the special
art and add new scenes the new scenes that they
added were the ones of el Aguila back in college
paying off the joke where he said in college he
did some matadoring but it was all part of this
drinking game that they were playing they show
She-Hulk in the yurt sweating it out with the
other super villains they show porcupine getting
his suit dry cleaned one of the things they
haven't paid off during these scenes though is The
Shield file on her desk like the prison that we
saw is a damage control prison it's not Shield so
we haven't seen any actual shield in the episodes
yet one of the other things I didn't mention in
my previous video when she was getting her special
super suits and they had the big Daredevil teaser
with Daredevil's new suit the person leaving her
right as she was walking in with that costume was
probably frog man who hasn't appeared in episodes
yet and he was a big person in the trailer there's
still an alarming amount of trailer footage that
we haven't seen in episodes yet meaning that
it's in the final two episodes and also like I
said there's Abomination footage with him in full
Abomination form which we haven't seen yet which
they'll probably pay off in the next two episodes
so that means they're going to be more abomination
in the series and I think we're all expecting some
sort of post-credits scene teasing Captain America
4 or like some big movie because there's so much
Hulk stuff happening in Marvel phase five we also
know that Bruce Banner's Hulk is coming back too
that's why she called him in a previous episode
like hey Bruce I'm wondering where you're at right
now hopefully they'll have like a concrete enough
teaser to give us enough information station to
guess on what it is they're going to do with him
next but if you spotted any other Easter eggs in
the episode that I didn't talk about in the video
just write down below in the comments like
I said Daredevil episode next week my video
will post after they release it and also they
released another Deadpool 3 Wolverine teaser so
I'll do a new video for that too everyone click
here for my Deadpool 3 Wolverine trailer video
and learn what's going on with him coming back
and clicking for my house of the Dragon episode
7 video thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!